[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre malgré les moyens
du Ségur de la santé et ses promesses
d'attractivité pour l'hôpital public
l'hôpital public continue de faire face
à un accentélisme important et pallier
aux nombreux postes vacants si l'intérim
médical est nécessaire pour répondre aux
difficultés temporaires de recrutement
l'usage abusif qui en effet conduire je
vous cite à un intérim cannibal qui
rémunère injustement le nomadisme
professionnel détruit la cohésion des
équipes certains professionnels sont
devenus de véritables mercenaires de la
santé font monter les enchères
hebdomadaires du marché de l'intérim à
2000 3000 euros par jour voire plus sur
certaines périodes tendues en
comparaison un jeune praticien à
l'hôpital perçoit un salaire mensuel
d'environ 4500 euros pour un engagement
sans limite auprès de ses patients pour
répondre à cette injustice la loi de
2021 a encadré les tarifs de l'intérim
médical avec un plafond fixé par décret
à 1170 euros brute pour une mission de
24 heures son implication prévue en
octobre 2021 a été décalé afin de
prévenir les dysfonctionnements à un
mois de la mise en oeuvre de la nouvelle
échéance fixée au premier avril nous
sommes alertés par les praticiens
hospitaliers notamment dans les services
d'urgence qui peinent à boucler les
plannings faute d'intérimaires acceptant
les nouveaux tarifs avez-vous envisagé
la réquisition de ceux qui profitent du
système au mépris du serment
d'Hippocrate pour éviter des fermetures
de lit ou d'urgence quelle mesure
avez-vous prises pour éviter un nouveau
recul dans le respect du temps de
travail des praticiens hospitaliers
titulaires et des patients qui ne
doivent pas être les victimes
collatérales de cette guerre de tranchée
entre le ministère et ses mercenaires
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la santé ou de la
prévention de Monsieur François Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
messenatrices monsieur sénateur madame
la sénatrice le héros la régulation de
l'intérêt médical est une constante et
une préoccupation du législateur depuis
au moins deux mandatures et vous avez
rappelé récemment une loi la loi risque
2021 c'est aussi attaché à ce sujet
je suis aussi très attentif au fait que
votre assemblée le Sénat surveille de
près la mise en application des lois
c'est pour cela que je me suis engagé à
mettre les décrets d'application de cet
article sur l'intérim médical en action
des débuts avril bien entendu et vous
l'avez dit cela ne vise pas l'intérêt
médical habituel mais bien les dérives
de l'intérim médical c'est des rives qui
forte heureusement ne sont que minorité
dans l'ensemble de l'intérêt médical
c'est d'abord une question d'éthique
mais même au-delà de cette question
éthique il faut rappeler quelques
chiffres vous l'avez fait
359 millions d'euros c'est le coût pour
les hôpitaux de l'intérim médical en
2021 vous parliez de chiffres jusqu'à
3000 euros ça va même jusqu'à 5000 euros
les 24 heures là où le cadre vous l'avez
rappelé de 1170 euros au-delà du côté
financier c'est aussi un véritable outil
à détruire les équipes hospitalières et
l'engagement des praticiens là où vous
avez deux médecins qui font le même
travail et l'un est le pays trois fois
quatre fois 5 fois plus que l'autre pour
la même période alors depuis plus d'un
mois j'ai demandé aux ARS d'animer des
concertations locales territoire par
territoire avec les préfets avec les
élus pour affiner les diagnostics
établissements par établissement j'ai
également je leur ai également demandé
de construire des solutions avec les
professionnels de santé du territoire
mais également avec les CHU les
établissements sièges de ght dont c'est
la responsabilité j'en appelle également
aux acteurs du privé des cliniques
privées qui se sont engagées envers moi
à suivre le même sens dans la
rémunération raisonnée de ces périodes
d'intérim médical je suis bien sûr avec
une attention très particulière
l'ensemble des établissements et des
établissements qui sont en fragilité et
je peux vous assurer qu'aucun territoire
ne restera sans solution
mais le cri d'alarme des professionnels
et moi je crains l'impossible mis en
oeuvre du plafonnement du prix de
l'intérim qui démontreait une fois de
plus l'échec de votre politique de santé
qui nécessite d'être revues de fond en
comble avec la profession je crains que
le respect du nouveau tarif ne soit un
poisson d'avril au mépris de ceux qui
s'engagent pour l'intérêt général auprès
des patients et sans reconnaissance